i think that
there's a lot of conflict with you know
the words in this title that
people have a lot of different views on
design uh
different ideas about
how you balance complexity and
abstraction
um and definitely about titans you know
we live in
a world dominated by by javascript and
dynamically typed languages and
we have to compete with that and really
make the case for
uh
what types by you and
and what you can do in type languages
that you can't do
or what you can do in strongly
statically typed languages that you
can't do in dynamically typed languages
because it's not just about method
dispatch and you know dynamic binding or
message passing um but types can buy you
a lot more than
um
you know just syntax
so
a little overview of what
i'm going to cover today
um
so the first i want to make the case
against what i call interface pollution
which is something that
is particularly pervasive in scala since
we have
wonderful traits at our disposal but
they're a little bit of a catch-22
because it's really easy to add
convenience methods to
your interfaces
and that can really hurt
the evolvability of designs in the long
run
and so i want to sort of
i have a running example that i'm going
to go through that
to really try and make clear
the different ways that i think this
interface pollution happens
and it's generally well-meaning and but
it really shows the ways that
it breaks down and fails
and then
as a
proposed solution i want to
show something that
is
rather unique to scholar which is this
idea of family polymorphism that you
don't have to deal with strictly
uniform classifier artists that using
particular combinations of scholars type
system that might seem esoteric at first
they come together in a really nice way
to let you
extend a set of types together
to
effectively have loosely coupled
interfaces with tightly coupled
implementations
and it leads to really nice results that
that
are
clear and
sound which is really really key that
the compiler can can thoroughly check
check your code um
and it removes a lot of
a lot of assumptions out of your code
allowing it to be simpler and
well-performing
um
and
then will lead to
yeah i don't really like the word design
pattern but for like what i call a
cupcake pattern which is
many of you may be familiar with with
the cake pattern and
this is the what i call a cupcake powder
is a there's a play on that that
favors using smaller cakes composed
together rather than these kind of
monolithic abstractions with
lots of types that
can become unwieldy
um
and then
we're gonna
and so i wanna i wanna be really
concrete at the beginning of the talk
uh and really give a motivating example
for for why this stuff is useful and why
why do you even you know bother with you
know would bother knowing that these
things exist and
because there isn't there's an energy
barrier sort of with complexity
i'm essentially advocating that you add
a little bit of complexity to the types
in your code to reduce the long-term
complexity and in particular
combinatorial complexity where
you know with every new module every new
feature you add you end up you know
multiplying the amount of work you have
to do by the number of existing modules
and this is something that
i found
to be particularly
pathological with with certain
scala designs where
things kind of run out of control really
quickly if you don't really deliberately
manage combinatorial complexity
um
and then lastly you know
like to end with a little bit of a
discussion and
you know q a generally but also hear
what others experiences have been with
uh
pushing scala's type system to its
limits um
so with that uh
let's start with talking about interface
pollution um and so the running example
that i want to use for this is
a simple abstraction which is the idea
of a number you know
it's
it's about as simple as abstraction as
you can get and yet it's deceptively
difficult programming
programming languages have a difficult
time abstracting over numbers and we all
have our
you know primitive ins and doubles but
but how do you effectively model
mathematical types
so
let's say that this is the abstraction
we want we want the ability to add two
numbers
and now how are we going to go about
this
you say
well we need to implement our
abstraction so
take a
we want a 64-bit you know double
implementation but how do we go about
actually adding those two numbers
we
are adding we've got a sub type here
that we're adding types of
some base type that has no other methods
so
there's not there's not a clear way
to actually add these things one way is
with the down cast of course
um
you can pattern match against the
specific type that you're working with
um
but
of course that's completely not sound
and you would never do that down casts
are are evil um
so
what you probably would find yourself
doing is going back up into the base
class and
add yourself a two double method there
now you implement that and this is sort
of classic oo design right
and you add your two doubles but
and that works great for
you know for one case but what happens
when you have another case so now we
want to do it for 64 bids that's also a
number
you
first of all you now
are missing
the implementation for
your your long
you know
implementation with your double
implementation
so you're forced to provide a conversion
but that's not so bad
um
but again what are you how are you
actually going to have these things
because you're going up against the
beast class again
and what you probably will do is go back
to the base class and add a conversion
for
further
along
and
i'm sure many of you have done this lots
of different times i know
i'm
guilty of it as well
and
the chord
i think that we accept that you can't
really have pure abstractions that you
know we're always you're always
going to tie your abstractions to some
particular implementation and i i think
that's just accepted as part of the
course but i don't think it's actually
necessary
and that's one of the the great benefits
that fella enables and we'll get into
the different ways how
and
so
in in that vein we've got this is what
traits are for right you can provide
some standard implementation and
you know
is it that bad an assumption to say hey
i want my numbers to be convertible to
doubles or to longs
but
it might be
what not every
the whole point of an abstractionism is
not to tie yourself to those
assumptions
so if you want to have represented
numbers as expressions of numbers
uh you know potentially with some
irrational numbers
well yeah you could coerce it to a
double but you're losing something there
and early more you're you're
by putting these conversions in your
base interface you're encouraging people
to use them and
you're going to make it's going to be
difficult to compose your code
in the long run
so
what what really are the the
consequences of designs like this and
again
i recognize this is a bit a bit of a
trite example because
it doesn't look that bad with
long you know too long and two double
but
it's not i'm sure you can imagine more
realistic cases you may have you faced
it
with your work where
you add things that you think hey in my
particular case that's no big deal and
it comes back to bite you later
so
the really the problems are that the
implementation details are leaking into
the interface that to longing to double
those were implementation details and
they've bubbled up to the interface to
make the optic model work
and really those implementations and
details constrain the interface
ultimately now the only thing you can
represent you can use your number
abstracted for things that are
convertible to long and to double
and
more generally any kind of assumptions
are constrained in your interface we
ideally we want to keep it nice and
simple and an assumption assumption free
another just
equally large problem is that the
implementation details leak into each
other
which is the fact that
when we went to implement in 64 we had
to implement the
the abstract number that was required
for float64
and so every time with with each new
case that you want to implement you this
is how you get that complement of
combinatorial complexity and it's simple
with conversions but
as you get into
uh
more casting
abstract members the problem can get out
of hand quickly and you tend to just
throw up your hands and you know give up
on
having useful abstractions or really
general abstractions
and
again the interfaces are involved with
the implementations that
you know it's a classic
idiom right that
you know keep your interfaces separate
from implementation
here we have
tightly coupled interfaces that are
tightly coupled with their their
implementations and then
the implementations are loosely coupled
with themselves because they have to
handle every every type of number
and so i consider these design errors
that are caught in growth time
and
again
numbers are
are
a simple case but they're a useful case
because because they're they're easy to
grasp
and
something that's an error that's caught
as you're trying to evolve and expand
your system in my opinion is kind of the
most pathological kind of errors that
combine compile-time errors are great
hey cats those runtime errors suck but
something that
you don't find out until you're deeply
you have a
deeply developed system that now
you need to
you know rapidly and reliably evolve
that's a really bad spot to be
so
avoiding it is really desirable and
worth the effort
um
so
we're really we really want here
to defer
so abstract methods defer an
implementation right say hey i'm going
to declare that these methods exist but
i'm not going to say what they do
what we really like to do
how might we actually defer the
declaration itself you know
ultimately maybe you do need
a conversion to double but do you need
that everywhere can you defer that
declaration to just the scope where it's
needed without sacrificing the
abstraction and sort of the general
the general nature of the interface
um
so
one approach which is is really the the
generic java approach taken by j science
which is a
an interesting library that models
numbers
is to use these
kind of cyclic
type parameters
where
hey we've got a ring here
that's parameterized with itself or with
some subtype of itself
and so now
your addition method there always adds
and returns sort of the the same type of
thing and this allows you to implement
your float 64 as a ring of float 64s of
itself this means you can
you're only adding the same type of
thing that you have so nice and simple
no pattern matching no down casting
because you're not working with the
general case there
so so that's one approach
um
but it tends to lead to
explosive boilerplate and is generally
awful
to work with and
so bad that
people don't work with it
um
and you can see that if you try and sort
of
a really important part of abstractions
you have to be able to compose them
otherwise you're not
you're not getting anything right that
in order to make that energy bearing
worth it you have to get to some deeper
simplicity or
you're really not getting anything you
would just use the specific types you
need
so if you have to have a vector
v some type of vector v r r is some type
of ring r
you know to just to get that little
that little method to work
you're not
it's not worth it right
now what about type classes
scala has
type classes can solve pretty much
anything by adding extra indirection um
and i don't want to knock type classes
at all i
i love them and they're great especially
when you don't have any control of
the original source
um but the thing about type classes is
they they still need classes they still
need some kind of underlying model so
they're good to to adapt
some
something that you have to work with but
when you're you're designing something
from scratch it's
it still just doesn't feel right in my
opinion i think that the design isn't
isn't right you can
you know have these self-contained
hierarchies that you then
abstract over with a type class which
and i think of time class is just a
detached b table pointer whereas instead
of
you you've just got a you know a struct
of methods effectively um and some type
type checking to go along with it
so let's get into
how we can do better i think you know i
would propose
with
family polymorphism um
and so
if we think
kind of from first principles about what
are we trying to do and what are we
failing to do with this abstraction
um is
we want to abstract our sets of values
together we want to abstract over a set
of integers or a set of floating point
numbers or a set of expressions without
mixing in between
um
and that's kind of hard to do with with
traditional oo
design
and so
we're going to get into the
kind of code that influences this really
quickly but
sort of the logic that goes into it is
that so you have types types to find a
set of values right
but install the values also can contain
other types
and this is really key
because every stable value actually
exposes an entire scope of types
and
that scope effects can contain abstract
types
where when you implement those those
abstract types you can you can tighten
the
which they actually refer
and this effectively reduces reduces the
set of values that that scope is going
to work with
handling sort of part of what we want to
do there which is work with disjoint set
of values
and so
every time that you have
some value that's typed with
you're actually referring to
values that you know have a common upper
bound even if you don't know what that
upper bound is because you're working at
you're you're working with sort of the
abstract
uh
base type
but let's get into the code to make it a
little clearer so
you know
with numbers we'll sort of generalize
just a bit to a field
of numbers
um or field of elements and so this is
similar to the interface that we started
out with right we've got
a plus method and a times method and you
know you would also have u very minus
and minus
um
and here's the key thing here is we have
an abstract type
whose upper bound is this interface here
so we're saying that
an element might be something more
specific than this but it's going to at
least have
this set of methods plus and times
um
and we'll throw in a you know a zero
there to
for the
additive identity of the field
but you'd also have a unit value
and now let's look at how you would
actually implement that
so you need to extend
you need some concrete class that
implements that field element interface
so you create a real element that takes
a double
and now
we need to define
what that sort of abstract element is
and
here we say that an element is always a
real element here and
on the next slide we'll sort of look at
graphically what we're doing with
the type hierarchies
and so we can implement our additive
identity
and you know a convenience constructor
and our plus and times l methods and
this this looks kind of like the the
jobby way with
the type parameters except that
there are no type parameters around you
in order to use this and you don't need
to specify
type parameters
so essentially what we're doing
we have this field type and we have an
abstract type element that points and
says hey my upper bound is this field
this field element interface
and when we go to implement it
we're injecting
the real element interface
as
we're tightening the upper bounds and
saying hey for in this scope and in any
abstraction that uses this soap even if
it's
through a path that's typed with the
the generic field
tape
we're always going to have this real
element as an upper bound so we can
depend on
on its methods which was
to double which was the the deferring or
i think it was value but
so we succeeded in
we succeeded in
deferring the
the declaration of that method
into a scope where it doesn't impact
other implementations and we've kept
this nice pure interface
while having a
still reasonably a reasonable looking
implementation
and another nice thing i think it's
important to keep simple things simple
while making sort of these these kinds
of abstractions possible and you can
actually pull out
that
the implementation of that abstract type
because we're
using a static object
to implement the interface
we can actually override that element
type and point to this top level real
class so you get a nice top level type
where you don't really care about
abstraction
it's it's still easy to work with
um and also notice that we're able to
take advantage of scala's value types
here so
the erasure of this real
real type is just double
when you have
class members that refer
that have real members they're just
double members there's no boxing
and there's a little overhead these
aren't
in line methods or
they don't use macros so
you are doing a static dispatch to some
of them but but the jvm is really good
at optimizing things like that so now
here we have something that
is analogous to what you would write if
you weren't giving any any thought to
abstraction you
just want to write some real wrapper you
know similar to give you the what you do
with a c plus plus template but you've
got this object
object real here which you can pass
around that that wraps up the entire
abstraction
um
and
so you don't get you don't get a whole
lot from this you know
i'll admit
well
before we get to
where you
the benefit really comes when you start
composing abstractions without adding
complexity um but i do want to just
quickly
uh sort of mention how you would use
these abstractions well first
you can use them again
like you would any other type and
just want to point out again here that
reel has the same eraser is doubled so
not all our costs there
you can use dependent method types which
we'll talk more about later to
uh say hey i wanna i wanna sum all the
elements in some field
and you pass in
you need some common baseline for what
field they're coming from you know to
say hey we're working with a common a
common set of things here so there is
there is a
definitely added
syntax for that
there are ways around the syntax because
which
is one benefit over over time classes
where the type classes you always have
to pass in that v table because
we're um
although these will be boxed when used
abstractly we do have you know a b table
and this pointer and so you actually can
add these without has you know with
the method that actually
just takes two arguments um
by saying hey we want some singleton
field and that that width single thing
is important to to let the compiler know
that you're working with one kind of
thing here um
and so there's there's declaration
overhead here but what you end up with
is a method that's it's easy to call
with and you know abstract values as it
is to just work with with primitives
so let's look at how
you would compose
compose these things because that's
where the the java and the type
parameter approach really starts to
break down
so
you know a really important case is you
know the idea of a vector space
where you've got some some scale or
field
and
at some level you wanna
most of the time you don't really care
what what that field is right you say
hey i'm working with a vector space and
it has some field that's consistent with
itself but i don't want to i don't want
to worry about that that's an
implementation detail
and so
we're going to use path dependent types
here on
this this bounce scaler
and we're gonna
so scalar is that that field interface
from from the previous side slide
um and it has an abstract type called
element
and we're gonna define the type alias
here to make it easier to work with so
everywhere that you see scalars and type
it's going to refer to this
scalar dot element this
this type that's dependent on this path
which is a stable value called scalar
and so we need some some actual
interface that that defines some methods
um
and say hey you know well vectors are
actually
uh
we can add them together and you can
multiply them by scalar among other
things
and we need another
abstract type here so we're doing the
same thing that we did with with fields
but
we're now
wrapping one of those abstractions in
another abstraction
and so we've got a nice
we've got an abstract type here we can
tighten the bounds later
to
provide efficient implementations and
you've got a zero vector also like for
the field
and now
you can abstract over vector spaces and
admittedly it's not
here's a linear combination method
using
dependent method types where you pass in
a reference to the vector space first
and then all the subsequent parameters
are dependent on that first first
parameter
although you can you can take the same
approach with
uh
singleton types um your projections from
from singleton types
um
and so you can do it
let's look at an implementation of
what a vector space might look like
so we want to
implement r2 sort of the space of two
dimensional
real vectors
and so the scalar field of that is just
the real field that we defined earlier
right
and so all you have to do is define
that value and assign it to
to
the the object that implemented the real
field
and now
we can find our vector class you can
actually override an abstract type with
a trait you can't override traits with
other traits but you can override a
type with a with a concrete class so the
abstract type in the interface was was
vector so we can just implement that as
a vector here
and again notice we're using the scalar
type alias which really refers to
scalar dot element
and also remember that this is a value
type so it's not box
this is
using
16 bytes of memory to represent the
vector plus all the junky object
overhead
and we have
a factory method to
make vectors to our two vectors
to find our zero vector and
our
scalar multiplication in addition
and nice and nice and concise right it's
not although
you can completely abstract over this
and in you know other other vector
spaces that you can implement there's
not a whole lot of overhead to
to actually implementing one and
again it's easy to use without
even if you don't care about
abstractions hey i'm doing some 2d
graphics library
and i just want
our two vectors and you can just create
vectors r2 um
one thing i didn't point out that the
uh the factory method for the real field
was marked implicit so you can
implicitly convert
doubles to reals
and again no boxing there
so you can use it nicely just a nice
concise syntax but you get
the abstraction when you need it
and that's how you would call the linear
combination method
um
and just to sort of make the case for
how
the benefits compound as you
as you add
capability
um
because
i think it is tough to make the case for
for abstraction like i said it's not
really buying you something so let's
look at what a matrix spice space might
look like an emitter space is actually
it's just another form of vector space
so any any matrix you can actually treat
just as a vector space
and we'll give ourselves a
self type there to refer to the outer
space
and like i said because of a matrix
spaces of vector space we can
define
vector we want to use an x-ray name
instead of you know when we know we're
working with a major space so we'll make
our abstract type we'll call it matrix
it'll be
bounded by some interface matrix element
and then we'll just make vector
an alias for matrix
and matrices have
row spaces and column spaces right
and so here's where
it starts to get interesting as as we're
we're building on on these abstractions
so like with the vector space we defined
that the scalar field on which it
depends it's a value and we use types
dependent on the path of that value
so
we're going to do the same we're going
to compose
a row space here
and we're going to say that's another
vector space
but
importantly
the scalar field of the row space is the
same
as the scalars field the scalar field of
the matrix space itself and so we use a
type refinement here
with
you don't often see type refinements
with this balance syntax in it but it's
really handy you say hey you know you're
it's as if you created some custom
subtype of vector space and overrode
scalar to be some type but
it doesn't doesn't create this is all
just typekeeping
um type
keeping
and like with
the vector space we can define row to be
row dot vector so the path so vector is
that abstract type
in vector space
and rho is the path on which we depend
saying hey all the vectors in the row
space come from this source
um
and we do the same for for call
so we've got nice concise syntax to work
here for rows and columns we've got
short short tightenings
and we can even model the transpose of a
matrix space similarly where we say
we've got some transpose space which is
a different matrix space and the row
space uh the transpose space is the
column space of this space you know
you know for the the column space and
like with the the row the row column
spaces the
scalar field of the transpose space is
the same as this
matrix spaces scalar field
so it kind of feels like a linear
algebra course probably to
you guys out there but
we're actually able to model it
concisely this is you know without
paying to matlab or some some custom
custom system that
your scholar can model this really
nicely out of the box
and with good performance too
so again we'll do our type aliens to
sort of flatten the transpose matrix
and
we'll fill in some some methods for
the matrix interface to multiply rows
you know rows and columns and we use
scala
as some of you know
use a colon at the end of
an operator
indicates that it's right associated so
the
multiplying the column times a row is
actually a left multiplication and it's
written written like that
um and again you can get the transpose
of a matrix but notice we've given
nothing about there's nothing about
elements here at all
we're just working purely with with rows
and columns
and so what does it look like to
implement this
because admittedly you know that was
there were a lot of tight incantations
in that that matrix space and
you know it's not going to be fun if you
have to sort of specify these all over
the place
so let's do a two by two real matrix
space
so like with the the r2
field we just define
uh the the stable value scalar
which is the the path that
identifies the types of all scalars in
this space so although we're defining a
valid here
we're using the types within that within
that object
and the the row and the column space is
the square matrix so they're the same
and because of that the transpose is
actually just the same space
and so nothing to do there except return
this
and we can
implement the
interface with
that
real field again
again remember that value types
no boxing
nice and efficient
we'll have our factory method uh
out there so we can use this r 2.2
treat it like a
constructor
have our zero matrix
you would also have identity in practice
and
hey you can return the transpose
i forgot to add
an actual multiplication but
because we're working with r2 there for
the matrix for
the matrix vector multiplication you can
directly access
or that r2 dot x and r2 dot y
um
because
we've
lowered we're using this r2 space we're
using the paths through there and r2
lowers the bounds of that abstract
height making
available
those those particular methods so
without any down casting in your code
you're able to
the the compiler will ensure that you're
always working with the same types of
vectors the same types of
columnar vectors the same types of
scalars etc all the the compiler takes
care of all those requirements and
constraints so that your code can just
look as
simple as as possible
and again you can use this
without caring about abstractions at all
um
and so
i call this pattern kind of the cupcake
pattern where
because it's essentially the cake
pattern that
you know it is used in a number of
scholar libraries but it's really
it's just that the cake pattern is
useful even if you have just a single
type
you know even in that example of a field
where
you
bringing your interface into this this
scope so that you can use it depending
on these you know values to
the sort of
uh so you get that ability to lower the
the tight balance and work with a
particular subset of values
um
so just to reiterate sort of what we did
is
we defined this this outer
this outer container for our type
and then we define
an interface that
declare the methods that the only ones
that we want to support no
implementation details just here's what
the abstract here's what the interface
is and you know go figure out yourself
how how you're going to go about
providing implementations we're not
going to get any help
and the abstraction really comes
not from the wrapper and not from that
interface
which is a which is a concrete trait
even there it's a concrete member of the
sort of this cup type even though
it's an abstract class it's a concrete
member
um
and it's this abstract type here where
we're saying
here's what the bounds are you know
you've got some if you're working with
this
uh
pass through this uh a value type with
cup you know you've got some kind of
this batter material but you don't know
what it is and it could be something
more specific than what you know about
and then you have
you declare some sort of ways to to get
values although often you might get
passed in instances of
of these types
um
and then and that's another useful thing
that these are
with sort of this pattern of having a
small wrapper around a single type
you often you need those identity values
or you need whatever their equivalent is
in some some sort of convenience methods
that aren't that you would put in a
companion object or a static method
normally
how do you get those things when when
you're dealing with abstractions and
um
and we've got a natural place to put
them
um
with this pattern
and then really what
what i advocate is instead of
taking the k-power approach and
this really isn't any d you could argue
that this is exactly the k-power but
instead of using a bunch of self-types
to
conglomerate
um a whole bunch of components into a
single scope
which definitely there are times where
that is necessary um
as much as you can have these these
standalone little cakes these little
cupcakes that that you compose together
it makes it easier to test you you've
got something against standalone
it works better in cases where you don't
you don't always care about abstractions
and
you know so
that was the this is kind of the pattern
that we took with the vector space in
matrix space where we declared a
dependency not through a self type but
through a value
and then
possibly import some type within there
just to flatten it and make it make it
easier to work with
so that's what i got with the cupcake
pattern in a nutshell
and what are the the consequences of
of this design
so the first is that
we encapsulated type parameters in type
paths
so we took we have
you know essentially end up matrix for
some type of matrix whereas that java
approach is
between all the types
and
it's completely unwieldy and
using
using this
the kick pattern and kind of stacking
nesting abstractions this way you can
maintain a constant amount of complexity
or even as you're adding a lot of
capability and that's really what we
want right is it's kind of a linear
growth of complexity as we're adding
capabilities and not this sharp spike
where
you know
uh
it's great at first hey you know we we
had all our convenience methods
everything that we needed so working
within our assumptions
we're golden but as soon as you're
trying to do something different just
the complexity explodes and you hit a
brick wall and you know refactor things
to death and you know qa gets mad and
all kinds of fun
but the most important thing
what i really
what makes
the key difference is this idea of
loosely coupled interfaces with tightly
coupled interface or implementations
and then
i think that this gets turned upside
down with a lot of uh optical design
because
you want those lucid coupled interfaces
and that tends to
lead
you can't really do it without
uh adding a whole lot of bloat and um
and getting stuck in that cycle of going
back up to the base class where if you
have to work with
every kind of a thing and every time you
have a new kind of that thing you end up
with this explosion of complexity
and
and that you really do want tightly
coupled implementations
is absolutely desirable
that that's what allows you to not have
to deal with you know
you know if there were no if statements
there there are no if it's a you know a
matrix of doubles there's there's no
quarter cases that you you have to think
about as long as
it type checks and you're not you're not
changing the
system you're golden
um and so in the timely couple of
implementations perform better too
so
although with that matrix implementation
well you could have done it where
you know
you could have implemented a matrix type
that used some abstraction over fields
and you box everything up and use type
classes
but
it's about as efficient as you can get
you're going to have you know we don't
you are going to box the matrices but
you're not boxing the
the actual values themselves and so
you don't really lose much efficiency
except for method dispatch and because
you've got distinct types for a lot of
these implementations the
um
you end up with in-line jump tables and
all the other you know goodness that the
the jdm is really good at
de-virtualizing methods and so
these abstractions are also very
friendly to to the virtual machine
and the optimizer
and
again what
what i like about kind of this cupcake
pattern is
one of the better oboe mantras of course
is favoring composition over inheritance
and
the cake pattern tends to be a lot of
inheritance right you end up mixing in a
whole bunch of different components i
mean sometimes that is that is necessary
um but to the extent that you can
compose these things the better and
although
as you notice that we we had all our
implementations were
objects they were they were top
top level things
and that's nice too because you're
rewarding at this point when you have an
inner class
that's implemented in a top level object
or so there's no outer pointer to uh
to the outer class the the skull
compiler optimizes that and implements
it as as a depth as a method that just
returns
the other class so you don't end up with
that extra that extra pointer
um
but there's something to stop you from
implementing a vector space that takes
as a parameter a scalar field so
although
this pattern works really nicely when
you've got a fixed number of variations
um and you don't need to dynamically
compose them it's certainly possible to
compose them at runtime too
so a few more reasons to
you know to like this pattern
um
is that these cupcakes can make
a nice form of enums too and
we use this at sensitivity where i work
where
we have to be really sure that
so there's a distinction between a data
type and
sort of the semantic type of thing that
that data pulls right
and so
you might have voltage values and
current values those are both doubles
they're the same data type but you
better be sure you're not you're not
mixing them up
um
and so
if you kind of use this pattern where
you've got sort of this abstraction of
the sensor and it's got samples instead
of you know the traditional way would
just be to use a top level sample type
with some
type parameter t and maybe a string that
identifies or you take any
as an argument
but but that new
uh
isn't part of the type signature and so
you still can get in
situations where you're mixing up values
between the problems but
here you can see when you you want power
you want a voltage sample in a current
sample and you multiply together
and you can't pass in you know
voltage for current and vice versa
and you you can get back
the
the sort of sample t type if you needed
and
existential type of the
they're a little they're not the
prettiest things um but
but they're actually quite
straightforward especially if you work
with you know javas uh wild card types
so they're going to define a little bit
but but they're easy to use here
um and this shows another nice thing you
can pattern matching against um
sort of
these sort of
style case
works as expected ingredient you could
do that with uh
you know deconstructing a sample that
hates as an argument or
some other idiom that you know
identifies the type of sample um but but
it's still it's nice and readable
um
and
it's actually it's great for for
reactive applications and you know
with very little inaudib
so here we just define this one sample
type but
there's a lot more potential that goes
along with the sensor you might have
buffers of sample values that you want
to store in a special format um but you
don't want any of your code that you
know works with samples to have to care
at all what the details of serializing
those things are so
you know this idea
of wrapping up your types in in in a
meaningful context and sometimes it's
hard to to figure out what
you know normally when
thinking about samples you know that
some sort of sensor type is not really
on your mind and
it's not always obvious what you want to
wrap your your types in to make them
easy to work with but
if you find yourself you know you have
some family of types that are
parameterized you know particularly if
they're paralyzed with strings or
something something unsafe
and you want to
you want to be really sure that it works
and that you know
in our case that you know the lights
don't turn out and you know newer
terminal b
then you
having the type system back you up is
you know
supposed to sleep at night
so i'm gonna
quickly
contrast abstract types with
or abstract type members rather with
inner classes
because it
it is a little weird how
you need these two declarations
scala doesn't have virtual classes which
are would be
the analog of virtual methods where
if you want to override method you don't
have to do anything special right you
just declare it as non-final but
type numbers are not overrideable like
virtual methods by default
or
concrete membrane traits are
as i think i see here so
if you just put a trait in another trait
that's it's still that cake
train is an abstract class
but it's a concrete member of
that vanilla trade and concrete numbers
you can't override or you you can't
tighten the bounds up you can only
loosen them
but when you have this this incantation
where you declare an abstract type with
some vowel
now you've actually got an abstract
number that that type
take is the analog of your virtual
method and so it does need to go in
these these two sets
to make it work
and you can see sort of the case here
you know there really isn't a difference
if you're only working with
you know
the base types you you don't really it
looks like you're declaring nothing like
it's just extra verbosity but
um when you want to go and extend that
interface then you see
where where the problems start to form
where you want to
make the cake trade something more
specific well you can't do that it's
already defined everything everything
that references or this vanilla squirrel
cake is going to refer to that base type
whereas with the abstract type
we've tightened the bounds so if you
have a chocolate swirl cake you've
always got you know that swirl batter
and
a little bit about a little more about
half dependent heights and how they
relate to
is a pretty natural extension actually
of qualified names
um
so you've got your typical package with
a class and so that's
you know
your normal ordinary qualified name
which you can import etc
but
if you've got a type inside inside a
trade you now you have to use this hash
you use a type rejection which is this
hash operator here saying i want to
reach inside and get the type
out of that trait
um
no
classes nested inside static objects are
just ordinary topical classes they're
just
syntactically scoped
and so you can just use that food up bar
like a normal qualify name
but the type is actually this tight
projection on the singleton type of the
object so
you know that's internally what the the
compiler treats
this funa r as
and where it gets
you know where skull really gets unique
is with these stable immutable values
and i remember when i personally scholar
looking at vowels and being like oh hey
that's just a way to
you know stop you from updating a
variable
um
but but
vowels are really much much more than
that they're not just a variable that
you can't update and
the key reason for that has to do with
path dependent types that
this value here although it's it's not
bound
it is a source of all you know
it has
all the types
it's got path dependent types relative
to it um
and if it was a bar then you could the
compiler couldn't couldn't prove that
you know
types or volumes typed with
dependent types through that value
aren't changing because you can reassign
the
var
so i think of a path of pentatonix like
qualified veins where
you can you can substitute in different
different implementations depending on
the context that you're in
and you can import them just like you
can if you have a if you have
a value you can import the
type members of it just like you would a
qualify name
um
and each each unique path kind of
overlays this unique set of types
um
which again is what gives you that nice
that nice uh
scoping that where you're working with a
fixed subset of values with that base
type
and um
dependent method types and singleton
types are way you know so if we're
saying that
all the types that you're working with
are dependent on some value well how do
you use them in some other scope and the
answer is with
dependent methods
types and singles and types which
until recently we're incredibly buggy
and we practice the power all the time
but since college 2.10 and they're
they're mature and
and they work nicely
and
so let's talk about scary existential
type projections
which the
the scholarly parlor now warms you away
from you know makes you
import some annoying language thing you
can use which i think is silly um
so the first thing
to know is that
i'll go to the next line so how do we
refer to
sort of
that inner type there and we said on the
previous slide that
you can do
but i want to show just the equivalence
of you know for thinking about
existential types in a simple context
that
really
the way you express that simple
constraint is well you've got c for some
type c is some kind of cup you're saying
hey
i
uh i've got some type of cup and that
that's just like a normal pipe down you
know in a really stupid way to put it
but
it's useful for thinking in the simple
case for when it gets more more
complicated
and so
before that inner time you say hey i've
got some type of cup
and then you take a tight projection
from that existential type you're you're
essentially saying i have some type of
thing i don't know what it is and i
don't care but i want
this i want some type out of it
um but again there's no way you should
never use existential types or for this
case you can just use the type
projection of the the top level thing
but there are cases where
you do need
the existential type so
um
it's worth considering the simple case
first so what if your outer type has
some type parameter um like with that
sensor example the outer type had
a type parameter t
and that's another thing worth noting
about why i like
um
the this sort of cupcake pattern for
wrapping up the noon style things is
when
there are arguments for voltage dot
sample and current dot sample you didn't
see double
anywhere in there they were they were
abstracted over those uh type parameters
and you can do that for you know like
with the matrix space you're
you're abstracting more type members and
you can abstract over type parameters
too and you can bundle them all up you
don't need to keep reiterating all of
these these tight bounds every time you
declare a method
so how do you refer to sort of the cake
inside that cup tea
if you try to do
the preferred approach up there the
compilers can complain and say hey
you have you want to keep some
you know help with some perimeter well i
don't know what that
wild card type is and
you know i give up
so here's where you do need
um
the existential type
so
like up there we say hey we've got a cup
of some kind of type parameter and now
the wild card type can exist there
you've got some kind of thing with some
bound and you want to get the cake out
of it
and a little bit about
type refinements
which we saw in
the matrix space example
if you want to say hey
a lot of times
what we ideally
we want to be able to specify
constraints when we care
and not have to worry about it when we
don't care right and and that's one of
the downsides of
the the type parameters approach is you
always have to specify them even when
you just if you just want some you just
want the default constraints specify the
type too bad
every method that uses then generically
acid has to specify each one of these
types
and type refinements are preferable
because you declare them when you want
them and you ignore them when you don't
care that they that they exist
um and so it's just a simple example
saying hey you want
you know you want a box of chocolates
you got a box and you specify
uh
the value or
if you have an abstract type you can use
the
uh type syntax for type requirements too
and then just to
reiterate a little about
the dependent method and singleton types
and this is sort of the nastiness that
i don't think is particularly nasty but
it sort of looks crafty until you see
what it binds to
and i think
you know seeing how you can keep
implementations kind of orthogonal and
how you can you can nicely abstract over
things
in my opinion really really
uh justifies the
the
the type funkiness that that you have to
go through in terms of what you want you
want to you want to tell the compiler
what the constraints are so it can help
you out
and so you need to you need to specify
that that some way
and so
you know um
it's important to note that for
dependent method types
you you need separate argument lists for
where you're passing in the path that
you want that your types are dependent
on
and then the arguments with the types
that are dependent on that path
and so here the cape parameter
specified the cape vets comes from that
cup parameter
in the first argument list um
and uh
the capital is going to complain if
uh
i forgot to play it will complain with
that second one there
and then
sort of
particularly not pretty
syntax or
using these tight projections of
singleton types where you're saying
hey i don't want to make the kind of
consumers of my library have to pass in
this
you know this object every time
you know
for this particular method that's maybe
called a lot
um you can have a type parameter
with the singleton type of the
um
the path
you're saying essentially that you don't
want a group of types you want some
specific type and then all the values
are going to come from the same place
and that that make sure that it's sound
um if you try and do it if you try and
omit this with singleton here
um there's no way to know that you did
pass in you're not passing in case from
from sort of these two different outer
types and so it wouldn't be sound
um
so that that's for button
so
in summary kind of scholarly system
definitely
predicting the outer edges of it that
i really don't see use used a whole lot
and
my
presumption is that
that people don't really
see the value or
um it's difficult to find ways to to
take advantage of it
but it allows you to do things that you
really can't do in other languages or
you wouldn't dare do
in
a
dynamically typed language
you wouldn't ever presume that
you know if you have some addition
method that you're going to get two
objects of the same specific thing you
wouldn't dare um so you add a whole
bunch of expensive guards you know
if it's this you know and a whole bunch
of
dependent dependent types are much
better than dependent behavior as much
as yeah maybe you know it would be nice
not to have to specify this sometimes
you can structure things so that the
type overhead is low
and what you gain from not having
to to to support effectively
undesired behavior and
where
it's just wrong
you want you can make it
invalid to use your types in a certain
way that allows you to simplify
assumptions uh simplify your code
and really make it
make it cleaner and and perform nicely
and
i've never seen another other language
that can do this quite quite as nicely
as ascaba and
you get a bit of a simple example with
with numbers but
you know
everybody here we're
building pretty pretty complex systems
and
i think that
we really need
we really need tooling to
to help us
do a better job at reducing the
footprint of kind of these complex
interacting systems
and
think that that scholars or something
like it really is that really that tool
and
um
i hope people take advantage of it and
really really put it to
use it to its full potential
and
so we're not so you don't lose out the
argument with with the java folks you
see hey you know
that
who see scholars hit you know okay it's
great that you've got typing for
instance but
but think that it doesn't really buy you
much that
um
and i think
it buys you a lot you
i guess
you know i'm sure a lot of people who
work on
you know
cloud software etc
you know we're obsessed with with linear
scalability of of our systems
um and yet we don't have that i would
argue with with a lot of the
the software frameworks that
you know we kill those systems with you
you have very non-linear
scalability
of abstractions and components and
you know scholar deserves
the name was chosen well as you
the scalable language
and
we should we should use it take
advantage all right thanks a lot